Imagine that there was a way
to send quantum information using classical communication alone,
but classical communication
can easily be copied and broadcast, so that means
the classical communication
could be broadcast to two
receivers, Bob and Charlie, let's say.
If they both received the
same classical information from Alice, then would
they both end up with Q?
That would suggest that we cloned Q, but we know that that's impossible.
Just as an aside, let's
observe that it certainly is possible to describe
quantum state vectors using classical information.
Every quantum state vector
you'll see in the series is being described to you
using classical information that was transmitted to whatever
device you're watching on.
In general, we could imagine
describing whatever state Q is in using classical bits
perhaps to some precision,
but that's not quantum communication, that's just describing
quantum states as vectors, and we'll come back to the
distinction between them
in just a moment.
Getting back to the scenario however, and working under the
assumption that Alice and Bob do share an e-bit, we will
see that Alice and Bob
have everything they need
to accomplish the task, and that's what the quantum
teleportation protocol does, specifically using two bits
of classical communication.
before getting into
these details, however, let me make a few quick
remarks just to make sure that the assumptions are clear.
First, we're assuming
here that the state of Q is unknown to Alice and
Bob, so in particular,
Alice can't send Bob a
description of the state Q because she doesn't know it in general.
We also have to consider the possibility that Q is correlated with other systems, including the possibility
that it's entangled
with other systems and the
transmission of this qubit to Bob must preserve those correlations.
Finally, I mentioned
the no-cloning theorem when I was talking about
trying to communicate Qubits classically, but
there's another connection here
with the no-cloning theorem, which is that if Bob
receives the transmission of this qubit Q from Alice,
then she must not have it anymore
because Q can't be cloned, and that's just something to keep in mind
as we consider the teleportation protocol.
The teleportation
protocol can be described in a pretty simple and direct way with the quantum circuit diagram as you can see right here.
It's slightly stylized in
that it depicts the separation between Alice's part and Bob's part, but otherwise, it's just
a quantum circuit diagram,
everything above the dotted
line represents Alice's actions and everything below
represents Bob's actions.
Time goes from left to right as always, and we see that we start
with these two Qubits here being in a Phi plus state,
so this is the e-bit
that Alice and Bob start with.
We can put labels on the Qubits to make clear which one is
which, so this is the qubit A, and this is the qubit
B that form the e-bit,
and this is the qubit Q that
Alice wishes to transmit to Bob.
Here we're hypothesizing that
the state of this qubit Q is Psi, but a little bit later on we'll consider the possibility
that Q is entangled
with some other system. And what the diagram is claiming because we've written psi down here,
is that this circuit
effectively does transmit whatever state psi we had
up here on Alice's part down here to Bob's part,
the only communication
that we have crossing the
line between Alice and Bob is the two classical
bits that are represented by these double lines right here.
Let's shrink this
diagram down a little bit so that we have a little bit more room and let's examine the
circuit more closely.
I've already described
the initial conditions, but just to recapitulate, Alice holds a qubit A
and Bob holds a qubit B,
where A and B together
are in a Phi plus state, so that's what it means to share an e-bit.
Alice also has this qubit Q that she wishes to transmit to Bob, and we're considering the case that Q is in some arbitrary quantum state Psi.
Now, we don't know anything
about how Alice and Bob came into possession of this e-bit.
It could be that they've
had it for a long time, maybe they created it some time ago when they were in the same location
and they've been saving
it for this occasion, but those details aren't relevant here.
The steps that happen next, which represent the
teleportation protocol itself are as follows, and just to be clear,
these are the steps that
the diagram describes and we're just gonna
write them down in words so that it's clear what
the diagram expresses.
Alice first performs a
controlled-NOT operation where the qubit Q that
she wants to send to Bob is the control and the
qubit A is the target.
The next step is that she
performs a Hadamard operation on Q, and then she measures
the two Qubits that she holds,
A and Q with respect to
standard basis measurements and we let lowercase a be the outcome of the measurement of the qubit A,